I wake up every morning looking for like  a genius  Pharrell was on my radar and just coming  up hearing about this this this Boy  Wonder genius that makes this incredible  new sound so it's my man okay all right  all right all right all right all right  all right all right all right okay so  this is what we wanna do what we wanna  do I called you did daddy's house in my  studio yeah then came in you had on like  a neon sweat suit or something your hair  was blond emmaireland blonde hey  sometimes you've got to go to storage  for them okay cool yeah your hair was  blond it was something different about  you so you know you met play me some  music you know even best of friends that  mistakes yes sir um I'm gonna go first  till you've been going first of all okay  cool but um you don't mind of course I  would tell you thank you for having me  such as a love fest we know each other  he's whipped me with my own but I'm  crying on the end of the phone I'm  laughing